So the other question that I had is more
of a personal question for me. Um
how does someone fight like the fear of
being like the fear of insecurity that
keeps us away from having a community in
the church?
>> So you're talking about not fear that
keeps away from the Lord. You mean from
fellowship with Christians?
>> Yes.
Well, you have to go to the root cause
of it. I mean obviously the way to be
healed of it is very intense deep prayer
and
fasting doing the spiritual disciplines
that the Bible and the church
assign
for God to grant you deliverance from
this bondage to insecurity. That's
obviously so that comes from deep
meditative prayer giving this insecurity
to God and say Lord redeem it for your
glory
and protect me from Satan using this to
hinder me from communion fellowship like
me. I suffer with body dysmorphia and it
hinders me from being not just going to
church. May the Lord have mercy on me
and pity me and not damn me to hell but
from even going out and meeting people.
I have the same problem because of my
body dysmorphia. But
speaking to you now on how God can bring
about that healing. It has to be
selfreflection like contempl
contemplative meditative prayer and then
as you're praying asking God to open up
what's locked in your subconscious mind
to go back to where it all started. So
this social anxiety that you have, this
fear of being around people stems from
something deeper that goes back to your
childhood.
So that maybe not something you want to
talk about publicly, but you'd have to
go see where it started. Why this social
anxiety, why does this fear to be around
people? Well, it goes back to something
at home. I don't know what it is. I
don't need to know. That's something
that is between you and the Lord and
maybe even going to the priest and then
confessing it. But that's where it
begins.
You've been damaged by something in your
past that has now been used of Satan to
handicap you emotionally from being
around too many people.
>> Correct.
>> Yes.
I I guess my fear is that it stems not
from trauma or something psychological
but rather that it's something from
selfishness like I like being alone so
instead of
>> but
why why are you comfortable being alone
like I'm comfortable being alone it goes
back to something deeper for example
with me the rejection of people in my
life that her
family,
the way they spoke to me, the way they
treated me, which then made me more
comfortable to be away from them so I
wouldn't constantly be berated and put
down. So my way of
protecting myself was isolating myself
from those who are supposed to love me
and affirm me. So I enjoy solitude.
That's what I'm saying. Why are you
comfortable being alone?
So I am comfortable being alone
for that very reason. And as I get
older, I'm more comfortable in solitude
than in communion and community. So I
don't have to deal with that. Now I it
wasn't always like this because people
are created for fellowship, for
communion, to be loved and to love. It
is not of God and it's not part of the
natural order of things the way God
ordered creation prior to sin and fall
and destruction to want to be alone. In
fact, people who like to be alone in
solitude,
they are socially dysfunctional and
awkward.
This is a fact. Like me, I'm I'm a
social misfit. When I'm around people, I
don't behave according to social norms.
I do things out of the ordinary that
from just a social perspective
would be deemed as offensive, rude, and
uncultured.
But I don't care.
But why I don't care? Because I
came to this point from
all the amount of rejection I received
growing up and criticism and negativity
and being put down that I didn't want to
deal with. And the way I didn't deal
with it is isolate. And I got
comfortable in my isolation.
>> So why are you comfortable being alone?
>> Um
I guess for a lot of the same reasons.
Um, like I I mean I grew up with two
sisters and even then I still felt like
>> separate. I don't I don't know if that's
the right word.
>> Like see the thing is that I would like
seek out their their companionship or I
would seek out the companionship of my
friends but I was never the one to
>> I was never the one to be reached out to
if that makes sense.
>> No, I know.
So that's why you're comfortable in
isolation. But that's not because you
were born comfortable
being isolated. That's your defense
mechanism. That's the way you protect
yourself. These are the walls to protect
yourself from further rejection, further
hurt, and from from feeling
not good enough because the reaction,
look what you just said. They didn't
reach out to me. So, what that does is
it's used by Satan to scar you, to make
you feel like you're not good enough.
>> I know. I've been there. You're speaking
to someone who's who's lived it most of
his life.
>> I know.
>> And I'm I'm not going to lie to you. Um,
shortly after I became I I was
confirmed, baptized, you know, all that,
I made my first confession and then I
felt really really good about it. I was
like, "Wow, I feel so relieved after
going to confession." And then
>> for about a quite a bit of time after
that, I stumbled because of that
loneliness. And I and I regrettably and
I really feel a lot of guilt about this
even though I just recently made my
second confession where I confessed
this.
>> I I stopped going to mass and because I
went didn't go to mass. I didn't go to
confession because and because I didn't
go to confession, I didn't go to mass.
And so it was like a cycle until I
finally broke it and I said enough and I
went to confession and mass on the same
day and I and I was so grateful that I
did that. But I think the reason that I
stumbled is because of that loneliness.
And part of the thing that's always been
in my head is well if nobody wants to be
my friend, well Jesus is my friend. So
>> that's the thing I've been using to
comfort myself, but I don't think it's
working.
>> Sister, let me share some with you.
That's that's the lie of the devil and
that's the problem
of having scars from rejection that
begins in your childhood that you think
no one wants to be your friend. The
church is a hospital. So there are sick
people. But the church is also your
family. And those who are being
ministered to by the Holy Spirit are
being changed in such a way as you're
being changed to no longer be so
self-centered as to ignore the needs of
their brother, sisters. This is what the
spirit is sent to do in us to produce in
us love for one another and to energize
us to want to be in fellowship with one
another. And the more we yield to the
spirit, the more we'll be in communion
and fellowship more we we will love. And
I'm going to show you that from
scripture. So that means you will find
your family in the church if you don't
just go to mass, take the Eucharist, and
run out.
See, that's also something you have to
look into because I don't know. I'm not
there to see you. Going to church to
take the sacraments is important. But if
you're just going there to take
sacraments and then you're rushing out,
then you're not allowing yourself to
interact and be part of the community,
especially if there are activities
during the week and you don't attend. So
that means you're only going to the
church for the sacraments. You're not
doing church to connect with your family
so they can get to know you and you can
get to know them. And that's what the
priest is there for, to know what your
needs are and then to direct you to the
right group. But here's what the Bible
says to you and I. And by the way, I'm
in the same camp. You're not the only
one. I'm in the same camp. I've been
carless since Friday. And I've been
locked in my apartment since Friday.
What day is it today?
>> It's technically Tuesday morning
>> by myself.
sitting on my computer researching,
writing, you know, getting into the word
by, you know, studying and and trying to
do live streams. That's it
by myself. Now, watch here. Here's what
the Bible says, though. Satan wins when
you're isolated. Jesus wins when you're
in community.
But I sense that like me, when I go to
church, I only go through during the
week. Why? Because of my body
dysmorphia. have gained weight. I can
only dress a certain way. So, I'll go to
the week because in let's say Wednesday,
it's not a lot of people and the people
go who are older than me. So, I'll send
it back, wait to take the Eucharist,
take it and I rush out. I'm not there
for fellowship. That's my fault. I'm
suspecting you're the same way. You just
go there, take the Eucharist, and then
you just dash out. Is that what you do?
That's exactly what happened this last
Sunday.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're like the female version of me
and hopefully you're not as ugly as me.
But anyway, please 4:8 to12. And I hope
you're not as bald as me. Are you bald?
>> I'm not bald.
>> Okay. Here's the what the Bible says.
And this is one thing that hits home.
You know when this hits home? When
you're sick
and you're all alone and getting well by
yourself. And it's going to tell you
right here because when I'm sick and I'm
in bed and I don't want to get out of
bed to get water, it's sure nice that
you have a family member that can come
and get you water, something as a small
task as water, cuz your body's aching
and you don't want to move. And yet you
got to do it. Now watch here. There was
a certain man without a second man,
having neither a son nor a brother. See,
all alone busting his back day and
night, saving this wealth for no one
because when he dies, he can't take it
with him. Yet there was no end to all
his labor. Ecclesiastes 48:12.
Indeed, his eyes were not satisfied with
riches. And for whom am I laboring and
deprived myself of good? This too is
vanity. It is a grievous endeavor.
Killing yourself working seven days a
week for no one cuz it's all you. Having
all this money in the bank for who?
You're going to die. Who's going to take
it? Two are better than one.
The Bible tells you right here, two are
better than one
because they have good wages for their
labor. For if either of them falls, the
one will lift up his companion. But woe
to the one who falls when there's not a
second one to lift him up. That's
exactly
what happens when you're sick. You
realize what happens if I pass out? What
happens if I have a heart attack? What
happens if I fall and I break my hip?
Who's going to be here to notice? Who's
going to be here to help me? Who's going
to be here to rush to my aid? I'm all by
myself. Furthermore, if two lie down
together, they keep warm. But how can
one be warm alone? And if anyone can
overpower him who is alone, two can
stand against him. A cord of three
strands is not quickly torn apart.
Notice three, the perfect number, the
triune God. But anyway, here's that.
Here's the point.
God says isolation is not what I created
you for. In fact, when I created the
male, this is the beauty about our God.
Every time he creates in Genesis, he
says it was good. It was good. It was
good. I know in the first day, evening
and morning, and we created heaven, he
didn't say it was good, but he didn't
say it was bad. The only time God said
something wasn't good is in Genesis 2:18
where the male was by himself and he
said, "It is not good
>> for the to be alone.
I will create him a helper." So, our
Lord is telling you, I did not create
you
to be isolated in isolation. That's not
good for you. And statistics prove this,
by the way. See, because the Bible is
God's word. It's supernatural,
historically accurate.
Everyday experience, everyday actions by
even creatures who are in rebellion
towards God, who don't believe in the
Bible, confirm the truth of the Bible.
Statistics have proven, ask any
psychologist, isolation will destroy you
psychologically and emotionally. In
fact, if you notice, some stalkers,
people are stalkers or serial killers.
are at people who are pretty much
emotionally mentally isolated.
But
point being, God is telling you, I did
not create you to be in solitude, to be
isolated. I created you for community. I
created you for fellowship, fellowship
with me and my body, the church.
I did not create you in isolation. Now,
as a Catholic, you're just going for the
sacraments. The church is not just going
for the sacraments. The church is going
to your family. Let me show you what the
church is. We're going to go to Acts 237
to 47. Acts 2 37-47.
So, we have to learn to do church the
right way. Now, here's where evangelical
churches
have an advantage over Catholic Orthodox
churches. And Orthodox Catholics, you
got to step it up. If you go to
evangelical churches, they have what's
called small groups, and they're always
encouraging you, always
exhorting you, get connected with a
small group. And they say it, you want
to be a successful Christian and live a
vibrant Christian life, find a a small
group. What is a small group? A group of
people that will meet in homes 7 8 9 10.
Because if you have a church of several
hundred, 300, 400, 500, 600,
you can't get to know everyone on a
personal intimate level. So they then
tell people start small groups and meet
a local group and connect so you become
family.
We don't Well, let me be careful. I have
not seen that in Catholic orthodox
churches.
>> I haven't either.
>> Say it again.
>> This is why Catholics and Orthodox,
you're losing the youth to evangelical
churches. Because another thing
evangelical churches have, they have
something called Awana, A W A N A, which
is once a week where you bring your
children and they have these programs
for kids to have fun and games and learn
the Bible at the same time.
You understand?
This is how they're getting their
churches to be filled. Now the people
that convert to Catholics orthodox are
the people who go beyond emotion and are
looking for truth objective truth and
they see from the study of the Bible
history the fullness of the truth are in
these churches
right but if people base their
conversion on emotional fulfillment
a lot of times people get more fulfilled
on an emotional level in these
evangelical churches than in the ancient
churches.
Right. But why is there an explosion of
converts to the Orthodox Catholic
communions? Because people
when they study church history, they see
>> the fullness of the truth isn't found in
my evangelical church, as much as I like
their programs, this is not the fullness
of the truth. It's over here at the
Catholic Church, over in Orthodox
Church. But then they come, they'll go
to liturgy mass, but they don't have
that same type of community they used to
have in evangelical churches. Ask former
evangelicals if I'm lying.
>> I'm a former evangelical. So my my
grandparents are my grandparents are
Presbyterian
>> about And you know about all these
things, right?
>> Yeah. Um, actually when I was growing
up, my grandparents would have me go to
like these Wednesday night things where
it was like dinner, games, youth group,
and then there'd be an hour set aside
where we would go with the youth pastor
into the chap into the sanctuary and we
would talk about the Bible, pray, stuff
that was relevant to us as, you know, 11
to 17 year olds. So,
>> yep. Exactly. Now, here's
what the spirit comes to do for you and
through you. Here it is. Here's Paul's
prayer. 2 Corinthians 13:14.
The grace of the Lord Jesus Christ is
favor. The love of God. Now, the love of
God means the love that comes from God,
but it's the love that God has for you
and the love that God fills you with to
love him and one another. The love that
is of God from God. The love that God
has for you. But the love that God fills
you with so you can love one another the
way God wants you to love one another.
Love him. And the fellowship of the Holy
Spirit be with you all. The fellowship
of the Holy Spirit is not just having
fellowship with the Holy Spirit.
It's the fellowship produced by the Holy
Spirit that results in the communion of
the body where we come in fellowship
with one another. And I'm hoping that
Richard is that heretic that I called
out. I don't know if that's you, man. I
hope it is so I can man. I'm I'm glad he
showed up if it's him. You with me
there?
>> Yes. Yes. Um
>> Yeah. And I I I agree with you that like
the Catholic Church and the Orthodox
Church needs that community a lot more,
the fellowship. And it's
and it's not just like in the church
that I feel separated. It's also at home
because I stand alone as the only
Catholic in my family
and the rest of them are well my cuz in
my household there's a gay atheist. My
mom is still oneness Pentecostal.
My my sister is pagan and my
brother-in-law is uh new age something
or other. So I stand alone as a
Catholic.
>> Yep. That's why you need the church to
fellowship there. Here, let me read this
and leave you with this. Mark 10:28-30.
So be intentional. Seek your priest and
tell them this is what I need community
because my family is all messed up and
pray for their salvation. Peter began to
say to him, Mark 10:28-30, behold, we
have left everything and followed you.
Jesus said, "Truly I say to you, there's
no one who has left house or brothers or
sisters or mother or father or children
or farms for my sake in the go for the
gospel sake except one who receive 100
times as much now in the present age."
Meaning now, not the future only, now
you're going to have new homes, new
brothers and sisters and mothers and
children and farms, but also
persecutions and an age to come eternal
life. So you see God's promise, he's
called you to a new family, to a new
home with new brothers and sisters. So
church, the Lord expects you to make
that a reality.
He expects you to be his hands and feet
and his mouthpiece. and he expects you
to make this promise a reality. When
someone gives up everything for me and
loses their family, they're coming to a
new family and that's where you step up
and do your part. So there you go,
sister. So be intentional and of doing
what you need to do to be in community
and fellowship.